if y'all will let me just let me pitch
the book I'm writing for just a minute
which is where all these positions have
come from I'm calling it the best I saw
in chess and it's not done yet but on my
computer it's about 500 pages there are
37 chapters in it it's all examples from
my career but it's really about the game
of chess yeah I think it covers almost
every aspect of the game nothing can be
covered comprehensively in one book but
everything is sampled here's how the
thirty seven chapters break down 20 of
them my 20 favorite games i played
counting down for game 20 against John
fedora wits to Game one against Sergei
Kudrin and then the other 17 chapters i
call them snippet chapters because their
little game segments and send it around
different themes there's four in Game
chapters there's three chapters on
tactics a lot of the stuff we're seeing
comes from one of the other the tactics
chapters there's a chapter on unblended
a chapter on fortresses a chapter on
middle games which i call pressing an
edge there's a chapter on cheating it's
an honest chapter embarrassingly short
games is another chapter games that are
20 moves at 71 I've put all of my losses
and that one compositions in the whimsy
five stories and their positions okay
just a great variety of stuff in the
book which is all possible because I
kept a thousand and nine out of a
thousand and eleven of my score sheets
from when I was a player it covers all
aspects of chess and if Magnus Carlsen
is watching this if you read my book
Magnus you probably have to retire that
would just like be the end all right
okay I'm going to make a confession on
this next one this next position here
this one here can you all see this Mayo
flip this a bit now you know that I'm
black in this position because whites
point is still on e 2 I never play with
white and that
one stays there more than one move this
is from a chapter of the book called the
closest I came to cheating and yeah this
is pretty close all right I would say
that this is this was my worst moment as
a competitor this is the most unethical
thing I did and I don't to excuse it but
I'll just tell you the story and tell
you what happened I was 13 years old
again I had the black pieces now my
opponent incidentally a man named Alan
Yeomans seemed like a nice guy but I
didn't know him my opponent had no arms
my opponent had lost both of his arms an
industrial accident in 1974 but he
needed no help playing he moved by
picking the pieces up between his teeth
and then when to hit the clock he used
guess the knob a kind of stub of where
his arm had been and then his penmanship
was beautiful he picked up a pencil
between his teeth and wrote with his
teeth and his handwriting his teeth
writing it looked great ok and now and
Alan Yeomans as white had played a very
solid game so this is the position equal
material rather symmetrical that you'd
have to say white has a small advantage
here just because whites pieces are a
bit more aggressively posted otherwise
everything is equal now I was not happy
about having this equal position as
black against the player 400 points
lower than me but what really bothered
me it was not just that was equal or a
little worse what bothered me was white
has no weaknesses here I really did not
understand how I could create any
winning chances so what I did was first
of all I played what I think is the best
moves Bishop c6 ok White's bishop on e4
is better than blacks Bishop over here
on the side a4 so I endeavored to swap
these pieces strategically correct
decision but then what I did was after I
played the move I got up from the board
as I always did and I did a double take
on the position and I stormed out of the
room
as if I was very upset by what I had
just done okay this is completely
illegal to try to trick your opponent
like this but I left the room and when I
came back in my opponent had resigned he
he could have called the tournament
director but he was at a Southern
gentleman and I walked back in and he
just said I fell for it and he resigned
and what had happened was he had played
the moon Queen take c5 as I had wanted
him to and he resigned because black
wins like this this ship takes bishop
taking a free piece and after blocks
queen is gone like this check on be one
with his rook white can throw his
rocking away and lose the rock but he's
just delaying the check made by one move
King h2 and rook h1 mate so it is what
it is folks it is what it is I cheated
against a man with no arms and compelled
his resignation from an equal position
without playing another move all right
let's go from my worst moment to my best
here what I want to shoot i want to show
you the combination of this game and
first of all I have to warn you this
will not have a very satisfying
conclusion because once I played the
combination the game then continued but
there's way too much game for me to show
it to you and electron combinations okay
having said that I'm going to try not to
talk too much about this game because I
am so freaking proud of this game I will
sound very conceited if I talk about it
but this is a game I play rose 11 years
6 months old and in this game I
performed the best single best
calculation that I ever perform as a
chess player and I have no idea how i
did this at age 11 and in my book this
is game number two
favorite game of all time so I want to
show you this calculation I perform then
maybe you'll like the combination even
if even if it doesn't in the game so the
player with white is my my oldest friend
the world my friend of 35 years Kyle
Farrell I love the sky we played lots of
great games okay let me go quickly
through these moves again I had the
black pieces we have a c3 Sicilian and
Kyle and I we knew this line and so we
played a lot of moves pretty quickly d4
pawn takes pawn Queen takes pawn play a
little inferior but it's a normal book
line at least it was back in the stone
Age's 96 Queen goes to e4 by place d6
night bd2 I play pawn takes pawn Knight
takes pawn this is all theory kind of
boring theory night scoops back to f6
attacking White's Queen white pins at
Black Knight on the E full on c6 I play
Queen c7 night DF three defending the
night on e5 let's develop a piece so I
don't leave it should be six Knight
takes bishop I sorry night takes knight
on c6 now I love playing cute moves so I
just play Bishop d7 I'll win the peace
back this way I think I didn't like
having doubled pawns when I was 11 I
play Bishop takes Knight white develops
this should be five ok now I played 95
now I plays Knight d4 ok crisis has
arisen early in this game all right
we're at a book at this point ok it's
blacks move now White has three pieces
bearing down on the c6 square black has
two defenders it is surprisingly
difficult I think for black not to lose
a pawn here immediately let me just run
run a few of the ways to lose a point
here 97 defending the bishop this is no
good White's going to remove the
ender Bishop takes Knight even Bobby
Fischer would give up his Bishop for a
night in this position j'adoube Bishop
takes Knight and went black recaptures
now wide again has too many things on
the black Bishop Oh a black wants to
lose more than a pawn he would play
Bishop takes Bishop here white plays
Knight takes bishop this is immediate
win for white bikes queen is a tag and
with this discovered check coming on
blacks King Knight takes bishop double
check White's going to win a piece
something big right away here but I
can't do that how can we defend the
square ok King d7 just don't make me
laugh you can't play a king of these
seven okay if Rick CA that's a
normal-looking move but it just it just
drops this pawn at a seven the point is
undefended finally ok again retreats are
hard to see this would be a move that
would stop the immediate problems but
after this move let's say that white
just at ratchets up the pressure on the
D file like this black has got problems
here black is not ready to castle here
and ok so all this makes this quite a
crucial position and it was in this
position that I made the best
calculation of my career so that there's
Anna color point in this game where I'm
going to say remember that earlier
position I saw all this from that
position so this is the position you
should remember right here not seeing a
good way to defend myself on c6 I made a
gambit of it and castle ok now Kyle
could do something boring here and bail
out start taking things and retreating
things but I had played a lot of garbage
against this guy in the past and he
thought this is more garbage and I'm
glad that he went in for what I regard
as the main line so he wins a point here
at Knight takes bishop I'll just mention
Bishop takes bishop here would not win a
pawn for white because black would not
take the bishop and whites Queen takes
the pawn but black can retreat is night
attacking White's Queen between
us to move it's too important the piece
to leave it hanging let's say you play
Queen B 5 now block attacks it again
very smooth here now the White Queen has
got nowhere to retreat to to move to
where it's still going to be on this
piece I mean maybe why to play this this
looks pretty normal black plays pawn
takes bishop like is not lost upon here
it's a comfortable position for black so
if Kyle's going to go in for a win of a
piece and Kyle was around 2200 player he
did it the right way he plays Knight
takes bishop all right Knight takes
bishop I played hold on yeah one takes
Knight and he goes Bishop takes pawn now
what am I doing here what am I going to
do having lost upon its not the same
move as before if Knight b6 here
attacking the White Queen the White
Queen has got no problem maintaining the
defense of the bishop of Queenie for now
f5 by black is not going to be any good
because why it's going to take this pawn
with check and you know but I could try
to do something here rook c8 may be
attacking the piece white retreats now
black it's like Queen c5 attacking two
pieces to white bishops along the
fifth-ranked but the problem is white
can save them both by first playing
Bishop d3 checkmate and one is
threatened on 87 and black has to defend
themselves against the checkmate and
then white can simply save this piece
white Sapong off white has a two bishops
White's going to win the game that was
not the idea
so is black here instead it should do
instead we're treating my night to be
six I played night takes c3 now usually
I like this sacrifice my opponent's
pieces but here the position demanded i
sacrifice my own so Kyle takes pawn
takes Knight and now I just calmly play
reggae c8 all right this is a good
position folks okay black is a full
piece down here but white has a big
tattoo go problem White's Bishop is now
double attacked if the bishop moves then
blacks queen will be taking this porn
see through your check some kind of big
attack is coming here I'm very glad
again the Kyle played the gutsy move and
he retreated his bishop okay first let
me just look at a couple other things
here aside from retreating the bishop
one point here is that white cannot bail
out by castling and then after Queen
takes bishop dining on this pawn on a
seven just the stars are lining for
black in this game because the white
queen is trapped Bishop c5 attacking the
Queen the Queen has one and only one
safe square to go to a five rook e8 see
you later queen white losses so this was
not feasible for the white player now
with a full benefit of computer-aided
hindsight White's best move here is the
exceedingly wimpy-butt correct Bishop d
to defending this pawn forcing black
j'adoube Queen on 84 where are you Doug
Queen takes bishop ok this is this
really where to taking the fun out of
the game Queen takes Queen rook takes
Queen and now having played Bishop d2
whites king is still in the center
that's where you want it on the endgame
the king is a fighting piece in the
center develop your king and the
the in-game Keaney 20 k equal material
probably draw now it's no fun that's no
fun I it's hard to criticize white for
any of the moves he made in this game
and this is one thing my sis in my
second favorite game to play a really
good game of chess your opponent has to
play well to just crushing someone never
makes for a great game and it really has
to be two good players playing two good
games okay so so white wants to hold on
to his extra piece and he played to the
best square if flights going to do that
Bishop f3 these are all specific tactics
let me show you why bishop efore would
be a terrible move it's because black
would take check here of the Queen now
attacking the king of the rook both so
white must move is king forward to
connect the two rooks for the defense
and black has this move damn hashmi Lee
okay Queens attacked bishops attacked
whites whites going down the drain here
the other square that I think is logical
to consider here for white is Bishop b5
and here's why Kyle rightly rejected
this move Queen takes pawn check again
the king must go forward to so the rooks
can protect one another likes Queen
checks down here if you will just take
my word for it if the White King goes
forward white gets in trouble so white
wants to bring his Bishop back here and
defend now black plays rook c2 attacking
the good old be hopper and d2 white
defends that bishop and now winning by
pinning Bishop b4 by black and now the
white Bishop on d2 cannot be defended
again by White's pieces black is winning
back his piece on d to White's King is
exposed black has an extra corn at least
for the moment this is bad for white
now some similar moves were played after
Kyle's choice of bishop f3
he goes Bishop f3 okay I checked as
we're familiar with white goes kini to
as before check here as before and white
plays Bishop d2 okay i play my rook down
to attack his bishop he wants to defend
his bishop and also kind of save this
piece here he plays work 81 and once
again I pin his Bishop with my Bishop
Bishop before so this is the same
position we just had with the difference
that's White's bishop which was on b5 is
now an f3 and with the bishop no longer
and be five white has this move which he
played Queen d7 okay Kyle thought Kyle
saw this he thought this is what he
wants to do this is going to be good for
white black is a full piece down here a
full piece down and I'll just mention if
black plays this its you usually look at
checks check King goes by the f1 no
follow up here for black there's no
follow up with the first position that
we looked at that rook and minor piece
in game I said that if all your pieces
are contributing to your attack see if
you can throw in a pawn but there's a
prior principle which is you won't halt
your pieces to be contributing to your
attack and here you see black has three
very nice aggressive pieces down here
and a rook that's not doing nothing and
what looks so strong to Kyle about this
defense is that the Queen on d7 it's
kind of crowding out the rook on f8 so
black has one piece that is not
contributing to the attack again I was
11 years old I'm so proud of this game
so here okay in my book I show every
every good thing I didn't chest
everything that I could show I show to
the book and then the whole 500 page
book I only have two moves I made that I
think deserve a double ! and this is one
of the two
okay i just i love this so much i played
this smooth bishop a fine another
retreat a quiet move okay the bishop
moved to a five it changes nothing in
the position except it opens up the
threat of rook da to bring bikes last
piece into the attack to bear another
piece down on the square of d2 and Weiss
has surprisingly few options here so now
what I want to do is show you two things
from this position I want to show you
what Kyle actually played which was
smart and then I want to show you what I
regarded is the main line in this
position which is this calculation and
I'm so proud of okay let me let me show
you what Kyle did first hee hee counter
attacked by attacking my rook and so
okay now I carried through with my plan
rook d8 now defended by the bishop and
to eliminate all these threats white now
simplifies the position gives up his
Queen Queen takes rook check Bishop
takes Queen Bishop takes rook Queen
takes bishop so this is the way
combination sometimes go especially if
the games I think you're very nice games
it's a combination that does not lead to
checkmate that does not lead to the way
of the Queen it leads to a much smaller
advantage so now we have a position and
this occurred in the game we're black as
a queen and a pawn for two rooks
basically even material distribution but
white is still exposed here this pawn is
hanging white hasn't gotten his rooks
out the long and short of it is black is
probably winning one more pawn here tips
the balance of blacks favor and so the
game continued and it was a lively Queen
versus two rooks position that happened
white played the move rookie one and
i'll stop here on the game but there's
one thing i had sort of a silly thought
about something to share with you a
silly thought okay one move I looked at
here was rook see one okay so why once
he gets his rooks out obviously black
wants to take the
and now it looks for a moment like this
is danger for bike this is bad for black
because now white gets his rook to c8
attacking the bishop the problem is it's
the scorpion sting of the tail end of
the combination queen a6 check forking
preventing this for white now here's the
silly thought that I had about this
whole thing the silly thought was if I
had done all this all this combination
the same way and my pawn is simply but
on a six rather than a seven nothing
would be changed except my combination
wouldn't work anymore because now rook
see one I just cannot take this pawn
rook c8 is too dangerous and move with
this not threatened I've got to do
something else here and I don't know how
this comes out but it's it's no longer
very good for black and so it's like
almost this kind of philosophical
question did I how do I put this was i
lucky that my pawn was on a seven or is
it they played very well so of course my
point is on a seven and I've decided
after a lot of thought that I was lucky
that the best game that you ever play to
the second best game is probably gang
where you're not only smart and playing
good news but where you also get lucky
and so I I was lucky that i had this
resource potentially okay so that not a
satisfying ending in terms of the game
because we're now leaving the game but I
want to show you the variation that I
calculated from this position should
yeah
you are correct sir you're correct sir
okay Chad you put that back Bishop a
five double exclam so I claim I was
thinking that the one way and white
might try to maintain his material
advantage here is to break the pin with
King e1 and now black should not be
tempted by this which might work in some
different position rook takes bishop
rook takes rook Queen check here now
this Bishop that's not doing very much
it plays a critical role here now blacks
attack is done maybe it's still an
interesting position but now blacks a
piece down and this is not what black
wants okay rather after King e1 breaking
the pin remember why it is still a piece
up in this position black should of
course now continue with this plan
visual a five rook d8 and now to try to
maintain White's material advantage
white tries to play Bishop takes bishop
rook takes Queen and rook takes rook so
now White has to root that's all right
erupted two bishops for the Queen that
is a big material advantage and whites
threatening maiden one down here and
black cannot mate White's King like has
pieces to put on d1 White's Bishop to
kind of controlling squares but but
black has a smooth to check hitting the
king hitting the bishop a double attack
so white moon is king over to tag blacks
rook black now plays Queen takes bishop
thank you very much now not only is
black captioning a piece here which is
good notice it likes queen is now
defending against the mate and then
white plays King takes rook and now now
look at this clinic for check whoops
check King c3 doesn't matter Queen takes
rook and black has a decisive material
advantage of Queen and pawn
for rooking bishop and now is the time
when I ask you to remember that position
ok before blackett castle Dwight played
Knight d4 he's got three pieces on c6
from that position before I castle i
calculated this 15 move variation Bishop
a5 was the eighth moving the variation
and it's all accurate and it wins for
black and I never I never saw anything
this could after the age of 11 so so now
let me let me show some kingside attacks
good old-fashioned kingside attacks and
maybe this is what you came here to see
ok let's make this position happen so I
have the black pieces against my friend
Jack Gwen why does a pawn down in this
position white second move against the
Sicilian was this be for the wing gambit
why you're still a pawn down from that
dubious decision it's black to move and
so here we go the first move is as
natural as a baby shrieking cry Bishop
takes h3 we all want to do this some
point another in our lives ok what the
attack begin the first thing I have to
show you is of course the pawn takes
bishop which white wants to play Queen
takes pawn White's problem here look at
these pieces over here everything is on
the queenside for white white has got no
defenders to his King white tonight is
attacked the night really can't move
because the bishop and the Queen are set
for a very crushing check here on h2
white can maybe protect this night with
his Queen Queen d1 now black plays
Knight g4 and white just cannot do
anything here why does no pieces he can
bring to the defense of this King likes
reading Bishop H to check with nasty
consequences and whites whites not in a
position to do anything
oh I should show you one other thing
here after black plays Queen takes h3
because there's kind of a recurrent
variation in this game if white plays
Bishop takes f6 I don't know quite why
why would do that maybe he's trying to
eliminate some potentially attacking
black piece black not only wins here
black just mates by force because like
starts to check why can come here check
back it's going to be the same thing
King f1 now black plays Queen takes f3
threatening checkmate in one move on h1
so white bring this King over to stop
that and now black check makes white
with nothing but checking moves just
very forcing check King f1 check these
are only moves for white king g one
Queen h2 check King shuffles over to its
demise Queen h1 is mate now ok so why
can't do that got that folks excellent
jack is a good tactician so after I
threw my bishop in to take the pawn to
h3 white then plays Bishop takes f6 how
old was I 16 years old the Alabama state
championship important tournament folks
Bishop takes f6 male whites hoping for
this this is a very bad move mechanical
very poor mode quantix bishop if I had
done that now white plays Queen takes
pawn and the position is completely
transformed now White's king is no
longer in any trouble Black's King is
open whites threatening the bishop mites
threatening this pawn I don't know
what's happening here but this is really
very bad for black to take such a strong
attack and to mess it up by playing
pollen takes bishop now a move black
might have played in this position I did
not play it move like might have played
a natural move Queen g4 rights nice to
threaten mated one on g2 now the game is
not over white can play night eh for
defend against the mate it's funny how
that bishop when f 6 which is attacked
which is doomed is nevertheless serving
a function here it's defending the night
ok I'm going to stop this variation here
to tell you the truth black whims in
this variation but i'll show you the one
that actually happened alright so black
is taking a pawn whites taken a night
and but i wasn't through with my bishop
over here i play Bishop takes pawn just
more destruction of the White King
position once again this move I'm
angling for this district current
variation I mentioned if white plays
King takes bishop why it's not just in
trouble White's mated Queen check King
here King here it doesn't matter Queen
takes Knight threaten made on h1 now
white plays King
you won it's the same thing as before
exact same position check check check
check mate ok the King cannot take the
bishop on g2 and live to talk about it
all right so why does a night attack
maybe black will take this bishop at
some point flex really bikes biggest
threat here just creates three Black is
just threatening checkmate Queen h3
threading Queen h1 mate White has no
defense night h2 Queen takes Knight is
checkmate the bishop covers the Queen
the White King is surrounded and
attacked so why cannot play King takes
bishop white must stop do something
about this Queen h3 threat and so what
Jack did was night h2 now white is
threatening King takes bishop III don't
want to take this check this is not
expect here White's going to take the
correct bishop here you simply King
takes bishop this way and black has no
twin in that position now a move that's
very tempting is to play Queen h3 again
it's a very strong looking move it
threatens made in 1h to now however mr.
Gwen has got something here he's got the
move of f4 so the move f4 cuts off
blacks bishop at the same time it opens
up the second-ranked for whites Queen
whites now threatening Queen takes
bishop and if black plays check here
this Bishop is once again triumphant and
it's a on pre square + f6 because White
has now d 4 white is hanging on by the
skin of his teeth here but white is a
piece up and black has things hanging
here so this is
run it through your computer some kind
of crazy position I don't understand so
what do I do here I don't take this
night I don't play qui h three whites
threatening my bishop white spawn may
come forward in some variations to add
white screen to the defense of whites
King so I make a third offering of the
Bishop Bishop f3 blocking that pawn for
the third time offering the bishop and
for the third time white cannot take
Knight takes bishop because of check
takes check check check mate our old
friend Bishop f3 all right white is lost
here is probably many ways to lose I'll
show you what happened here white plays
Bishop h4 natural-looking move white
finally rescues his Bishop he hopes to
bring it back to the defense of this
King but now I simply went Bishop takes
Knight check King takes Bishop and this
rather effective move Queen g4 so now
made in one is threatened on g2 may just
threatened takes the bishop Queen h1
mate and if here now it's made on h1
Queen check King back that's what they
call mate so white resigned after this
Queen g4 move and the last thing I'll
say about this particular position is a
just like it made all the difference
whether my pawn was on a six or a seven
the previous game it's suddenly very
important the black spawn is on 86 and
not 87 because if this point had been on
87 then all this would just be away for
black to lose because white would then
have the defensive move Queen g5 for
taking the bishop protecting the square
whites a piece up but with a pollen 86
covering the clean no can do
alright let's see another King side
attack alright I had the black pieces
here again smiles art oven alright
what's happening in this position it is
equal material now White has the two
bishops here but the two bishops are not
important Oh Doug where's my man where's
my man why does not a rook down sir
thank you equal material the most
important features of the position are
that White's King is opened up and white
has to poorly placed pieces Bishop
passive on e 1 and this night is looking
irrelevant on a 3 that's White's problem
another problem the White has is the
weakness of the e3 Square and black
makes variations will happen where black
will get a knight or queen or something
in III and then it's going to be very
hard for white to get out of that okay
those those are whites problems now on
the other hand it has to be said that
black does not have a typical attacking
formation here black is all Plex pieces
are out first of all blacks missing a
bishop you might like to have as
LightSquared bishop here the bishop he
has it has a tagging potential although
I you might say it's kind of a bad
bishop with all these black pawns on the
same color square as a bishop maybe that
matters Black Knights they protect each
other but black doesn't really need his
pieces to be protecting each other here
he might rather his knights be on
squares that just attacked unoccupied
squares ok it's not a perfect attacking
position for black but nevertheless
white is going down here with accurate
play my first move here is black was
again i love these or treating moves
this wasn't easier than the others i
played my queen bag 286 this has two
purposes here the first purpose i'm just
attacking a pawn on h3 like white better
do something
about that the other the other purpose
this move between 8-6 the queen is
undefended on g5 and so therefore
White's clean on this diagonal here
black cannot move this pawn in this
position without losing us queen now on
86 the queen is defended by black
special on 86 so now and white does not
want to play pawn takes pawn Knight
takes pawn it's a very strong square for
that night so now in every variation
every move that white considers white
must reckon with two possibilities with
ass black pawn quantix pawn or f3 and
what we have here is a position in which
white has got a wide variety of losing
those there are a lot of ways to lose
this for wipe and let me let me show you
a few of them just to give you kind of a
feel for the position if white defends
this pawn let's say is Queen goes to g2
now f3 is the crushing move for black if
white plays Bishop takes pawn the Queen
comes into III check and that puts
another piece on White's Bishop on f3
White's losing a piece here White's
losing a bishop why doesn't want this
and if f3 if you can't take that pawn in
f3 then you've just got a very sad
position I mean your queen is going to
go over here j'adoube this queen is here
I don't know Queen check maybe actually
I'd play Knight takes pawn first Bishop
takes Knight Queen check this is this is
not not much fun for white
if white plays h4 in this position to
defend the pawn now black will make use
of the fact that this G foursquare is
available for his night the Knights
coming into it p3 this line goes on but
maybe you can take my word for it 94
threading 93 bad news for the white bits
let's see what else might we try kingi
to ok I'll let the seller this be the
last variation of the siding from what
happened King g2 is a very normal move
not kh2 now this would allow Knight g4
check that is a very bad thing to happen
to white if King g2 now black again has
a very forcing win with f3 check white I
guess we'll take this pawn if he moves
as king you'd have to move it here keep
a defense of this pawn but now Knight g4
check will take the king of Waveland
offense that point Queen takes pawn this
is disaster for black for white but
let's look at the main line f3 check
Bishop takes f3 this is simplicity
itself here folks Queen takes Queen
chess Bishop takes Queen knight takes
Bishop rook takes Knight and now with
rookie to check and black wins the
bishop on d 2 y place King f1 rook takes
d2 ok peace in my pocket white resins
black wins ok so all that all that is
not good when you look at all these
moves for white all these natural moves
are all getting crushed by something it
just shows it's hard to play a chess
game when you've got one piece doing
absolutely nothing on a three and then
your king is a bit exposed and and you
eat healthy
okay so what my friend from Florida did
was to protect this point he plays Queen
h2 all right now I play pawn takes pawn
now i'm looking to get my queen into
that III square so miles first stops
this where i first plays rook takes rook
check i play rook takes rook and now he
plays Queen takes g3 alright so why it
has succeeded in protecting his pawn
he's succeeded in deterring black from
infiltrating to e3 but now blacks got
night f4 the quiet night on g6 joins the
attack and it's it's raining down in
whites position the two immediate
threats naughty to check forking the can
queen that's a good move and then this
pawn is now double attacked so miles
plays th2 trying to meet both threats
and here's how he met his end I took
this pawn anyway might takes h3
White's next move makes no difference to
anything white checks like puts his king
of the corner and now with this night
threading the move and to attack White's
King some more white took this and
here's how the game ended Knight g4
check by black the King does not want to
come up and expose itself to more
dangers the King goes over to g2 now
this the weakness of this e3 square
comes into play light plays 93 check
again white doesn't want to move as king
forward and have new problems now it's
made in one actually that's a problem
okay so King age to staying on the
defense of the Queen now the bishop
hasn't been doing much now it comes into
its own there should be five check
attacking White's king why is again why
does not want to relinquish his queen so
white plays Bishop g3 and I took it off
which it takes g3 check and this was the
end here miles resigns because King
takes g3 Queen f4 is made one of my
favorite chess quotes at the end of this
lecture about combinations here's the
quote I probably I probably read too
many chess books to think this is funny
but the quote is a brilliant see is when
you attack your opponent's piece and he
can't defend it now my translation of
this is what I saved my book is don't be
brilliant stupid just play good moves
combinations are great when they happen
but they're rare and what will happen
over and over in your games as you'll be
able to tag the guys peace and he won't
be able to move it and maybe you won't
want to show that in a lecture but
you'll still win the game thank you very
much